So we'll now build truth tables for conjunctions and disjunctions and
negations of sentences, so that we can find the truth of complex sentences
stated in logic. Now many of you probably are familiar with truth tables, and
if you are in fact familiar with truth tables, then you can skip this part and
go directly to implication elimination. If you're not familiar with this then
please stay with me, but even so I'm going to go through this quite rapidly. So
here is the truth table for A or B. If A is true, then B.
If A is true and B is true, then A or B is true. If A is true and
B is false, then A or B is still true, because A was true. If A is false and
B is true, then A or B is true, because B was true. One of them is true,
makes this true. If A is false and B is false, than A or B is false.